just warning this report from Cordelia
Lynch contains images that you may find
distressing
the despair
some searching
so many morning
their loved ones killed in a night of
Chaos
this the emotional Aftershock of one of
the world's deadliest ever sporting
events
is a match between Indonesian sides a
Rhema FC and
persevere in the city of milang Drew to
a close Aramis fans who had just seen
their side lose this fixture for the
first time in 23 years ran onto the
pitch they clashed with police
certified tear gas a tactic now under
scrutiny it sparked panic and a stampede
scores of people many of them children
crushed to death
Indonesian authorities claim the stadium
was over capacity
the police had already taken
preventative action before finally
firing the tear gas because the
supporters were already attacking the
police and burning Vehicles after police
fired the tear gas they all ran towards
the same direction to exit gate number
10 and 12 causing a massive Jam during
the jam shortness of breath occurred
because they were running out of oxygen
in hospital many are seriously injured
violence at games is nothing new in
Indonesia but this loss this Carnage is
colossal
I regret this tragedy and I hope this is
the last football tragedy in this
country a tragedy like this must not
happen anymore in the future
the league is suspended the
investigations underway
the hurt overwhelming
Cordelia Lynch Sky News